[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le pire est à venir selon Emmanuel
Macron le chef de l'État français qui
s'est entretenu il y a quelques minutes
avec Vladimir Poutine la situation va
s'aggraver parce que les Ukrainiens
n'ont pas des nazifiés et la réponse
d'Emmanuel Macron ça a été tu te
racontes des histoires et tu cherches un
prétexte pour envahir l'Ukraine que
s'attendre aussi regarde et mouvement
des troupes russes à des situations
peut-être de siège de grandes villes
rappelez-vous à l'aide rappelez-vous
grosse nid etc et là ça peut devenir
très grave donc le désastre continue
c'est un cauchemar il faut absolument
fermer le ciel ukrainien parce qu'ils
sont en train de tuer notre peuple
depuis le début du conflit des avions de
renseignements sont aussi mobilisés tout
comme des avions pour la livraison
d'armes et de transport de troupes on
montre les muscles on montre qu'on est
un allié fiable et solidaire de l'OTAN
alors donnez-moi des avions
sinon je ne peux pas lutter
les États-Unis
et en otage le peuple ukrainien et on
voit très bien d'ailleurs que de Georges
Soro savhl en passant par l'un des
Macron tous ces gens qui défendent un
même monde sont des gens qui estiment
qu'il faut arracher
l'Ukraine la ramener du côté des
occidentalistes pendant que tous les
slavophiles sont des gens qui sont des
méchants
des incinérateurs pour assurer la
crémation de leur propre soldats ce qui
est affreux tu as quelques mois de cela
qu'en penser la grande majorité de la
population
ukrainienne et bien que zellenski est
laissé dans la misère les laisser dans
la pauvreté ne s'occupait pas
effectivement de leur sort et finalement
travailler avec les oligarques
Ukrainiens la majorité des Ukrainiens
ont été intimidés ont été
intimidés leur cerveau ont été lavés par
une propagande test de la liberté à
Carson alors que des chats russes
occupent les lieux des Ukrainiens les
défis au cri de gloireaux héros de
l'Ukraine l'un d'entre eux se saisit de
deux drapeaux Ukrainiens retirés d'un
bâtiment par les soldats russes même les
brandis courageusement au milieu de la
place sous les yeux des Russes il a
choisi son camp mais quel camp le camp
effectivement d'une Europe libérale dans
laquelle il s'agit de dire oui si vous
voulez appeler ça la liberté mais c'est
la propagande qui nous dit que c'est le
camp de la liberté ce n'est pas nous
c'est votre ministre des Affaires
étrangères Jean-Yves Le Drian qui a
évoqué la menace nucléaire là c'est une
rhétorique qui est complètement
inadaptée irresponsable et
disproportionnée leur souci c'est leur
influence leur influence économique de
positionner leur pion à leur intérêts à
eux c'est des affaires de grosses
journalistes dont lave Rove parle nous
faisait savoir effectivement qu'il y
avait des exactions commises par l'armée
ukrainienne au Dombasle elle a fait voir
des images dans une émission je crois
que c'était celle de Pascal Praud on n'a
pas eu le détail de de cette du nom de
cette journaliste mais effectivement il
a disparu très vite parce que d'un seul
coup elle sortait il rentrait avec une
télévision couleur alors qu'on nous
propose la télévision en noir et blanc
une lettre aux Français tenant en une
page ennemie Emmanuel Macron prend la
plume pour se muer en candidats ambiance
de campagne au salon de l'agriculture
Marine Le Pen était en opération en
séduction hier avec un arrêt au stand
outre-mer très remarqué première mesure
à partir du 14 mars suspension du passe
vaccinal et deuxième mesure à la même
date on a voulu quelque chose de simple
fin du port du masque obligatoire au
stand au sud-ouest Jean Lassalle n'a pu
résister un Paquito comme dans les feras
de la région mais sur ce coup le
Béarnais semble peser un peu plus lourd
que dans les sondages